very much glare ladies and gentlemen
there are three awards for short
subjects so we have three presenters
view ratification all nominees for best
supporting players for their
performances in Rose Tattoo East of Eden
and picnic ladies and gentlemen miss
Marisa Pavan miss Jo VanFleet and mister
author O'Connell
the winner for one resource subject is
the Basel City Edmund Reid
we'll accept commentary on behalf of
every week of the staff thank you very
much thank you for two real short
subjects so that you won't be confused
ladies and gentlemen one of the main
differences between a one real short and
a two real short is Lane I would like to
present miss Jo van sleep the winner is
the face of Lincoln will Berkeley bloom
dr. Mayer okay talk to the Lincoln head
in the film
on behalf of the cinema Department the
University of Southern California I
accept this I present mr. author
O'Connell ladies
the winner is speedy Gonzalez
Edward selfi director of the khartoum
were like seven for mr. self
thank you very much